the weekend reveals using drugs as a  crutch in a new interview with The  Guardian when I had nothing to do but  make music it was very heavy drugs were  a crutch for me there were songs of my  first record that were 7 minutes long  rambling whatever thoughts I was having  when I was under the influence at the  time I can't see myself doing that now  the weekend admits to still using drugs  recreationally when he has a writer's  block he's the best we're still great  friends and I'm excited it's a second  show so I know he's going to kill it and  you know we're all celebrating together  so it's just gonna be a fun day the  artist recently made headlines for his  split with Bella Hadid who remains one  of his biggest supporters the two bumped  into each other backstage and on the  runway at the Victoria's Secret Fashion  Show I am so excited the Adrenaline's  finally pumping I am ready to go and I  can't wait to walk on that runway  [Music]